good morning John it's the first of
August I know that you like me I know
that you like watching me and I know
that this is vaguely entertaining
however I have to say that I think that
there are more entertaining things in
the world for example I recently would
to see a breakdancing crew practice
responsibly the list didn't anything
I've seen outside of YouTube since Grand
Rapids Michigan and today I just want to
show you that and that is all that I
want to do and I'm gonna show it to you
to the tune of 21 Jump Street not the
theme song from 21 Jump Street no it's a
song about 21 Jump Street by DJ wise and
Red Cloud courtesy of sin tax records
thank you very much for a long e to use
that in the show and of course I'm using
huge fantastic thank you to zoo as what
an only breakdance crude wouldn't matter
if there were 10,000 of them you guys
would still be the best breakdance crew
in Missoula they're really fantastic and
it's quite a surprise to find out that
that kind of thing is actually going on
in this town thank you specifically to
will for helping to teach me to
breakdance and for inviting me to watch
his crew so sit back relax and enjoy
because this is gonna be awesome
[Music]
in London - you're married again Sam
with the body so done so far even the
devil Mirko lapis lapis aisle 6
it's rain
[Music]
besides
Hornets
[Music]
hope you enjoyed that and I have a
little bit of an update about Chicago
we're a little bit worried that there's
not gonna be enough space in the library
where we're gonna be speaking so are
asking people to pre-register and you
can do that in the sidebar I don't know
that's actually gonna guarantee you
anything that there are too many people
there don't worry we'll figure something
out I promise second I'm gonna be part
of a wizard rock show at around 10 p.m.
the night of August 8th at a club called
red newsroom and you can get tickets for
that in the sidebar - oh my god that's
exciting anyway John I'll see you soon